d'abord il ya un petit sujet comme quand
on distinct discours du président de la
république sur le thème du terrorisme
on peut attendre un peu de hauteur ça
n'a pas été le cas ce matin on a eu
droit à une espèce de salmigondis où il
a parlé de tout et où il s'est auto
glorifier de tout auto congratuler 2to
débiter des banalités affligeantes sur
ce qu'est le terrorisme etc nice est mis
en contradiction direction pour
luministe parce que quand manuel valls
et face au terrorisme c'est la guerre
c'était pas du tout la position de
hollande qui était plutôt sur le thème
ouais ouais d'accord il faut lutter
contre ils ont faim en sortant pas des
règles classiques et c'est donc ce n'est
pas la guérir
est ce que c'est un disque offensif non
quelques petites piques pardon de bas
étage contre la droite contre nicolas
sarkozy
aucune annonce en dehors du fait qu'il
était content de son bilan qu'il
envisageait par conséquent d'être à
nouveau candidat
c'était le discours d'un premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
devant des militants disposaient à
l'applaudir non pas sur ce qu'il annoncé
pour la france mais ce qu'il annonce et
éventuellement dans le positionnement du
parti socialiste contre le droit ce
matin c'était un candidat tout court pas
du niveau présidentiel sur le propos
déjà du niveau candidats ils essayent
visiblement de contourner la primaire
socialiste d'apparaître comme celui qui
éventuellement peut y aller même si les
sondages le disent totalement
discréditée voilà
pour le reste de monsieur hollande
s'adresse aux militants socialistes qui
vont voter pour la primaire ça
simplifiera de jeu ça nous évitera
d'avoir des discours en direct d'un
président de la république qui ne l'est
plus hollande n'est plus le sujet pour
la droite et son bilan est telle que
c'est pas lui qui peut essayer de porter
une espérance à gauche nous nous avons à
parler aux français qui ne se
reconnaissent pas du tout dans un propos
présidentiels ou auto glorifier ils y
vivent mal et du chômage ils ont des
difficultés de vie ils ont l'insécurité
ils ont la peur du terrorisme
il se demande ce que devient la france
dans tout ça voilà c'est à des réponses
vraiment de fond crucial des français
que la droite doit répondre et pas du
tout se lancer dans une quelconque
polémique avait quelqu'un qui va essayer
de réexister par la polémique ne le
faisons pas existé ne le faisons pas
vivre laissons le continuer de
s'écrouler ou régler ses comptes avec
ses amis socialistes